you know what let me tell you a story
okay i was in first grade and my teacher
was a woman my first grade teacher was a
womanist i was going to
garbage at school on the south shore of
montreal called kaleshwaransa
what a go i'll leave that in leave that
in
and i remember what clearly one day
she was going around the class asking
who wore the pants in the house
so do you wear the pants and we're like
what does that mean miss
well i'm gonna tell you what that mean
who takes the decision in your house
people will like answering my dad my dad
my dad my mom my dad and
my mom and your mom all right yeah
my dad and everything every day someone
was saying like my dad
should i push who spends more money who
she would go more in depth you know what
i mean and then it was my turn
and she's like who wears the pants in
your house and i'm like
i don't know and he's like she's like uh
i explained to you with that
man no no no no no no no hey hold on i
i don't know doesn't mean i don't
understand what you're saying
i don't know is the answer to your
question
i don't know you must know so who takes
the decision
well sometimes it's my mom sometimes
it's my dad okay okay
okay who cooks sometimes it's my mom
sometimes it's my dad okay who makes
your lunches
yo she was drilling me who makes my
lunches
well when my mom is no hold on
well when my mom is home she does my
lunches
sometimes it's my dad when he's there
and sometimes it's me because they want
me to do my lunches so i'm learning to
do my lunches
so yeah she was drilling me and she
couldn't even
okay but what does your mom does for a
living she stays at home like no she
don't
she works for this company what does
your dad do i was like well my dad's a
doctor my dad's not a doctor my dad's a
nurse
but i'm i'm at that age i don't know
what the difference is
he works in the hospital he a doctor he
a nurse
same same they wear white they got trans
coats on
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't know it's
strange it's not really trans cold it's
a little
whatever lab coats
i'm like that's a trench coat i don't
know the difference
i don't care i got bigger problems than
this i don't know how to count
you're spending all this time not
teaching me and
she was you know what she did she called
my parents
she called my parents to figure out if i
was lying or not
in her head i was being auntie son i was
trying to you know yeah i don't know i'm
really equally because it was not
possible
it was not possible for her to end them
the fact that my parents
had an equal balance and she was super
happy when it was a woman that had the
pants she's like yeah
it's mostly women that have the pants
i'm like what
maybe in their houses but i don't know
about that but me
it's always been 50 50. i was scared of
my dad
i was scared of my mom as well you know
what that means
in a bad situation my mom was saying uh
wait till your dad get home
it's because her arm was tired and it
was time for for round two because i
really [ __ ] up
i was not scared of one more than the
other in that sense
my dad is just because of the voice i
remember the voice
oh thank you this is trap let's take the
money and run
but yeah she was so stuck in her thing
that she had to be
and do you feel like it's because of our
like political views definitely yeah
now that i reflect on and it was 100 i
know it's not all of them that are like
that
it's not all women it's not it's never
all it's never we know that it just
surprised me that she had
just that um
agenda behind it she had to find like
the twists or ways on that and that i
was like yo this is
yo this this book calm down lady it's
just
it's not that it's not that deep what's
the moral of the story
the moral story is chill chill
calm down your ideal of what you want
maybe it's not ideal because what you
wanted what like technically
the definition of womanism is equality
but often that is not the rhetoric that
i see
they don't want equality they want
superiority
or they want to be what men are
or they want to be what men are and i'm
like no it's
what doesn't mean being the same no it
doesn't mean being the same same i mean
we're different at different things like
it's
but it's okay you have your powers i
have mine and that's what
makes it one so being different it's not
a disadvantage it's not
it's not because you're different than
men or you're not exactly like man
that i could do everything like you why
would you want to do that
why everything you can do i could do
better i can do anything better than you
why would you want to do that
yeah why just do the [ __ ] that you want
to do
that you can't do and it's fine and it's
perfect
sometimes it's just too much man yo it's
not who cares i could do
that better than you i don't care you're
not helping
if we're in a sinking [ __ ] and then
there's there are different tasks doing
the [ __ ]
and i'm like yeah i'm gonna do this and
i'm doing it right now and like
i could do that go find something else
to do we're sinking
i can't fit in that [ __ ] do it that's a
woman's job is that what you're saying
girl what are you saying
you know go to that
i could do it better than you you're not
kidding we're thinking right now do
some not right now sometimes and i
understand the reason why it is there
the reason why
we need that we need womanism
we need men's right activists we need
black lives we need to balance a balance
that's it balance you know that's what
that's what i see that's pretty much it